now what does this thing mean we know
what the gradient function tells us it
tells us when this thing's positive I'm
going up when it's zero I get stationary
points when it's negative I'm going down
but what does this tell us what's going
on okay sir we'll come to a language in
a second let's first think about like
we're stationary points we were looking
for when the derivative zero well when
is this thing zero when when what value
of x makes this zero and the answer is x
equals zero makes the second derivative
zero where is that have a look where is
it it's a it's this spot here see that
and that's what there I'd love you to
add this or maybe to another color if
you've got it at that spot right there
the second derivative is zero okay now
what's special or that that about that
spot we don't know yet I need two T's on
this a little walk okay you remember I
mentioned to you before when you're
determining the nature of a stationary
point you'll know whether it's a maximum
or a minimum depending on what's
happening in the neighborhood what's
happening on either side okay so
therefore I'm interested on in what
happens on either side of this spot okay
what happens for instance to the right
hand side when I put in positive values
of X what is the sign of the second
derivative it's also positive six times
and any positive number also positive so
on this side over here when X is
positive my second derivative is
positive okay
what about over here on the left what
about when X is negative when X is less
than zero six times X is also less than
zero does that make sense so over here
on my second derivative is negative now
what does that correspond to
look carefully at the graph sorry I keep
on using so many colors but you know how
I am with colors what's being described
is do you see over on this right-hand
side I want you to imagine it it's a bit
like a kind of like a valley isn't it
right there
every part here is facing upwards like
that right whereas on the other side
this part of the graph if you have a
look at the curvature of it it's facing
downwards like so okay in particular
have a look at this spot in between the
arm in between the turning points okay
do you see that the gradient is negative
that's why it's going from top to bottom
but it's going negative in different
ways
here's a function it's going it's got a
decreasing gradient it's going from top
to bottom
okay now this function here is still
going down it's still decreasing right
but is it getting faster or is it
getting slower up here up in my right
hand over here it's closer to a
stationary point it's slow up there
because stationary means it's not moving
at all but then it gets steeper and
steeper and steeper it's speeding up
isn't it okay as it drops off now this
is still decreasing this is also still
decreasing you start high and then you
go low does that make sense
but is it speeding up or slowing down
it's slowing down isn't it down here if
I could bend it far enough it would
become a stationary point see there it
is okay so in between here and here
while the gradient is still negative
it's still going down okay
it's going down in different ways and
that's what this thing is telling us
okay our name for this feature you can
make your heading now is concavity
concavity is a word that we use we
associate with lenses right like a arm
like a camera lens we would say it's
convex or it's corn cave right so you
can see if you picture this is a side of
a lens right we would say that this part
here I think my colors view this part on
the left hand side is concave down
if you have an exceptional memory you
might recall back when we were talking
about parabolas you ever did lock us to
the parabola and we were like you can
make what parabola space up-down
left-right
I used this language I said a parabola
can be concave down or as over here I
could say it's concave up okay so what
this means is the sign of the first
derivative tells you increasing
decreasing but the sign of the second
derivative tells you concave down or
concave up okay
so that's so important such a big idea I
want to write that down okay
the sign of the first derivative dy on
DX right what it tells you is positive
means increasing and negative means
decreasing okay but when you go to the
second if you differentiate the game the
sign of the second derivative d squared
Y on DX squared based on positive or
negative positive means this guy concave
up facing upwards think of like a cup
this cup can hold water because it's
facing upwards okay so this is concave
up whereas on this side if you think of
a couple the water's coming out the cups
facing down concave down if you have
whoops a negative second derivative okay
so how do we use this why do we care
about this well number one it helps you
understand the picture a lot better but
it turns out to also help us back over
here let me rub this off we now know
what the second derivative is right so
therefore we can say hey you know these
stationary points like say when x equals
negative 1 when you put in x equals
negative 1 into the second derivative
what do you get like what's the actual
value
well yes six times negative one that
gives you negative six okay but we're
way way the sign of the second
derivative if it's negative that means
you're concave down concave down you're
facing downwards so that tells you in
one hit rather than going to the left
going to the right that tells you oh
that's a maximum do you see that you see
how it's concave down likewise if I said
X equals one let's put that in the
second derivative what value do you get
6 which is positive so that's facing up
it's concave up so what kind of turning
point do you have well it's a bit of a
okay so this is really useful right it's
not just to work out what things look
like how they're behaving but it also
helps us do what we were doing before
faster and more efficiently okay so it's
a red idea with lots of notation by the
way whenever you see something with lots
of notation that's a big ticket for you
to know oh this is important lots of
people care about this engineers care
about it physicists care about
economists care about it and every
single group will come up with their own
notation that they like so when you see
one idea one idea and everywhere there's
a million ways to say it
that means it's useful in a lot of
contexts we really care about the first
and second derivative okay